Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Diciotto minuti
per cercare di parlare
del buon uso del mondo,
quando, a poca distanza dal qua,
abbiamo distrutto il nostro mondo,
della Liguria, di Genova.
18 minuti non per parlare di fotografia
ma per parlare, per cercare
di convincerci, se ce la farò,
di come piccole e grandi fotografie,
o grandi e piccole fotografie,
possono portare un piccolo
cambiamento sociale
e cambiare non il mondo ma dei mondi.
[Pensa e scatta in modo diverso]
17 minuti e 30 secondi adesso,
per parlarvi della nascita
di questa mia idea,
della fondazione di Shoot4Change
di come l'ho avuta, sviluppata,
di come sta crescendo
e di come si sta consolidando.
Shoot4 Change nasce,
in realtà, quasi per caso:
come spesso accade
alle, ex post, buone idee,
nasce con un blog.
Provenendo da una vecchia tradizione,
una vecchia storia di blogging
e di fotografie di viaggio,
comincio, subito dopo
il terremoto a L'Aquila,
e poco prima dell'avvio
della "Marcia Mondiale per la Pace
e la non Violenza" due anni fa,
a bloggare sul potenziale
di cambiamento sociale
delle grandi fotografie del passato.
In poco tempo, comincio
a creare una community,
anche se non ne avvertivo la presenza.
In concomitanza, appunto,
con la Marcia Mondiale
per la Pace e la non Violenza
partita da Oakland due anni fa,
mi contattano gli organizzatori,
da Oakland, della marcia,
e mi chiedono di poter
coprire fotograficamente
il passaggio della marcia
nella tappa di Roma.
Avendo poi altre vite parallele,
perché Shoot4Change è la vita,
la seconda vita parallela;
certe volte mi sento non tanto
quanto come Clark Kent e Superman
ma più come Paperino e Paperinik
o Pippo e Superpippo,
per le vite parallele,
le vite a castello che conduco.
Mi chiedono di fotografare
il passaggio della marcia,
io ricordo che non potevo,
in quel giorno a Roma,
e faccio un post che adesso
affettuosamente ricordo di aver chiamato,
probabilmente anche in maniera
un po' troppo provocatoria,
"Chiamata alle Armi Fotografiche".
Vedete come questo ossimoro
ritorna spesso nella nostra terminologia.
Già Shoot4Change è un ossimoro,
perché in inglese "shoot"
significa, allo stesso tempo,
scattare una fotografia ma anche sparare,
e change è il cambiamento sociale
ma anche i soldi.
Tanto è vero che, all'inizio,
alle prime settimane di vita
del nostro network,
che è diventato un network
internazionale di volontariato -
avevo un grosso picco
di accessi da Washinghton.
Evidentemente, temevano
che fossimo un gruppo di mercenari
che sparavano per soldi.
Poi si sono tranquillizzati,
e hanno capito che, in realtà,
siamo solamente
dei poveri fotografi di strada.
Quindi ho fatto questa
"chiamata alle armi" fotografiche,
e in poche ore mi hanno
letteralmente intasato la casella postale,
da tutta Italia,
e siamo riusciti in pochi giorni
a coprire non solo Roma, non solo Milano
ma gran parte del nord Italia
fino ad arrivare a Lecce.
New York, San Francisco,
fino ad arrivare alla fine in Argentina -
su dei picchi delle montagne
dell'Argentina -
dove la marcia ha concluso il suo cammino.
Bene, lì ho capito
che forse si poteva fare qualcosa.
Ho capito che la gente aveva voglia
di scendere per strada
e raccontare la propria storia.
Le proprie storie,
dal proprio punto di vista.
Allora abbiamo cominciato,
continuato a bloggare,
chiedendo alla gente di -
non solo di raccontarci
le loro storie di prossimità -
uno dei nostri slogan, dei nostri claim
è "Shoot Local, Change Global"-
ma di venire a farlo con noi,
o di chiederci un aiuto
quando non fossero stati in grado
di farlo da soli.
Uno dei messaggi che cerco di dare,
che cerchiamo di dare,
con le nostre attività
e con i nostri reportage
è non solo di par - ma di non illudersi,
di doversi mettere necessariamente
nei panni del grande fotografo
del National Geographic -
che peraltro molti di loro
sono nostri membri volontari,
da Ed Kashi a New York
per National Geographic USA,
a Alfonso Rodriguez,
National Geographic Spagna,
e altri grandi professionisti -
ma che al grido
"Shoot Local, Change Global"
è sufficiente scendere sotto casa,
magari armati di una macchina
fotografica compatta, o uno smartphone,
e raccontare le storie di prossimità.
Quello che abbiamo chiamato
la "Fotografia Sociale a Chilometro Zero".
Da qui il claim
"Shoot Local, Change Global".
La finalità - o meglio, alla fine
il risultato che abbiamo ottenuto,
e che stiamo ottenendo,
e che stiamo consolidando,
è un invito alla sensibilizzazione
ad un'osservazione più puntuale
e più - scusate il gioco
di parole - sensibile,
della realtà che ci circonda,
chiedendo alla gente
di prendere parte attiva a un cambiamento.
Per noi, il nostro concetto
di fotografia sociale
non è solamente stimolare,
dare un cazzotto
nello stomaco dell'osservatore
facendo leva sulla classica
estetica del dolore,
la drammaticità delle immagini,
delle tragedie.
Noi chiediamo di portare un contributo.
E soprattutto cerchiamo di raccontare
quelle storie positive,
ordinarie o straordinarie,
che nel nostro piccolo, dietro casa,
portano un sollievo, un beneficio
nelle situazioni di disagio sociale.
Ci sono una miriade di storie.
Di tantissime piccole, o piccolissime,
o minuscole, in alcuni casi
associazioni di volontari
che nessuno conosce.
Noi raccontiamo gratuitamente,
ci prestiamo gratuitamente
a realizzare servizi
professionali fotografici
a chi non se lo può permettere.
Dando quindi accesso,
in una logica di vero
"citizen journalism" all'informazione,
a tutte quelle storie
considerate non remunerative
dall'informazione mainstream,
e sono tantissime.
Alcuni ci hanno accusato,
all'inizio soprattutto,
di essere quelli che lavorano gratis
e che distruggono il mercato,
e distruggono le agenzie fotografiche,
o i giornali, perché lavorano gratis.
Non è così.
Io rispondo spesso a queste persone:
"Ma tu racconteresti mai
la storia di un centro per senza dimora?"
"No". "E perché no?"
"Perché non me le comprerebbe nessuno."
E noi lo facciamo.
"Entreresti mai
in un centro per rifugiate?"
"No, non lo farei mai
perché nessuno mi comprerebbe
quelle fotografie."
Noi lo facciamo.
E col tempo ho sviluppato
questo concetto di "Crowd Photography".
Ricordo spesso, cito spesso
in occasioni del genere,
il vecchio e famoso detto africano:
"Se vuoi andare veloce, vai solo.
Se vuoi andare lontano, vai con altri".
Un fotografo va bene
per raccontare una storia.
Due fotografi vanno meglio.
Tre fotografi sono ancora meglio.
Quattro forse sono ancora meglio.
Poi si comincia a fare casino, ovviamente.
Però più si è meglio è,
perché ogni storia ha almeno 360 gradi,
360 punti di vista per essere raccontata.
E questo arricchisce il racconto.
Il concetto di Crowd Photography,
è un concetto in base al quale
quasi tutti i nostri progetti -
ci proviamo, non sempre ci riusciamo -
sono il risultato dell'apporto creativo
di persone che magari non si conoscono.
E credetemi, il nostro metodo
sta crescendo e si sta consolidando,
non solamente con i fotografi,
ma con creativi di tutti i generi.
Abbiamo pittori, designer
che ci regalano i loghi.
Abbiamo musicisti che compongono
e ci regalano le musiche
per i nostri Slideshow.
Abbiamo giornalisti, abbiamo scrittori.
Abbiamo tutti quelli che hanno voglia
di mettere le idee in rete e condividerle,
e aggiungere un tassello
alla storia, con le loro idee.
Cerchiamo di essere non convenzionali,
nei nostri racconti.
Anche qua, spesso ci riusciamo,
a volte non ci riusciamo.
Ad esempio - questo è giusto
un esempio che vi ho portato -
può una foto di un cavallo,
o una serie di foto di cavalli denutriti,
raccontare la recessione
economica in Europa?
Sì.
Questo è un reportage
che un nostro membro italiano -
ma vive da tantissimi anni,
giovanissimo, in Irlanda -
non è mai riuscito a piazzare
a Dublino in alcuna rivista,
perché in Irlanda non vogliono parlare
di queste storie sociali
perché, dicono le riviste,
danno un'immagine distorta dell'Irlanda.
Lui ha scoperto
che una delle conseguenze inaspettate
della recessione economica
è che gli irlandesi,
che tipicamente sono sempre stati
molto propensi ad acquistare i cavalli,
quindi a vivere l'outdoor
in maniera molto piena,
vendono, o meglio svendono i loro cavalli
in alcune fiere gestite
dalla malavita irlandese
nei sobborghi di Dublino.
E li vendono a 20, 30, 40 euro
cavalli già malnutriti.
I ragazzini ovviamente,
spinti dall'entusiasmo,
li acquistano o li barattano
con cellulari;
salvo poi, dopo due o tre giorni,
non potendo più permettersi la gestione,
non sapendo dove metterli, in casa,
li abbandonano nelle periferie di Dublino.
È una storia che nessuno voleva comprare:
noi l'abbiamo pubblicata.
Ha fatto il giro di internet,
ed è una maniera non convenzionale
di raccontare un episodio,
purtroppo, di cronaca mondiale,
come la recessione economica.
Ma facciamo anche cose non tristi.
Raccontiamo non solo storie tristi
ma anche storie molto positive.
Questa è una dei mille esempi
di progetti che noi teniamo ogni giorno.
Insieme all'associazione
sportiva Liberinantes,
che noi seguiamo da anni, ormai, a Roma.
È un'associazione composta
da rifugiati politici e richiedenti asilo,
che usa lo sport per affrancarsi
dal ricordo delle tragedie
dalle quali scappano.
Siamo entrati in un centro
di accoglienza a Roma, La Casa di Giorgia,
composto da rifugiate,
che da accoglienza a rifugiate,
donne, e richiedenti asilo,
e abbiamo scoperto
che queste donne, queste ragazze,
non erano mai state nel centro di Roma
nonostante fossero arrivate a Roma
già da mesi - in alcuni casi
anche da un anno -
per paura del traffico, della città,
dell'inquinamento, degli italiani.
Erano imprigionate nella loro gabbia,
che si erano auto-costruite,
di luoghi comuni.
Allora noi le abbiamo divise
in vari gruppetti,
abbiamo regalato a ciascuna di loro
delle macchine fotografiche compatte,
le abbiamo fatte affiancare
da alcune nostre ragazze fotografe,
anche per una questione
di maggiore facilità
di raggiungere una fase di empatia
tra docente e allievo.
Gli abbiamo insegnato,
grossolanamente e velocemente,
a usare una macchina fotografica;
e siamo andati in giro con loro,
nell'arco di un mese e mezzo,
tutti i fine settimana a Roma,
portandole letteralmente con noi,
trascinandole con noi.
Si sono divertite tantissimo.
La macchina fotografica con la quale,
poi, hanno raccontato la loro Roma,
e stato un filtro che le ha concentrate
a guardare Roma attraverso una scatoletta.
La tesi del nostro progetto
è che una città che conosci
è una città che col tempo riconosci
e una città che riconosci -
anche attraverso
le tue stesse fotografie -
è una città nella quale
trovi un livello di fiducia tale
che ti consente di ricreare
e di riappropriarti
di alcune dinamiche sociali
e quindi di inclusione.
La piccola mostra fotografica
che abbiamo lanciato dopo questo progetto
ha fatto il giro di Roma,
e comincerà a girare adesso per l'Italia.
È stato un successo enorme,
la stanno chiedendo
in tantissimi altri centri.
Queste piccole fotografie, forse,
hanno cambiato il loro mondo.
Adesso cercherò nei minuti -
che non vedo più,
tra l'altro, sullo schermo -
che mi rimangono,
sette minuti e 48 secondi,
di smantellare il concetto.
Probabilmente non è vero,
vi ho detto delle fesserie,
la fotografia non cambia il mondo.
E invece.
Questa persona per esempio,
l'ho conosciuta nella
"città dei morti" a Il Cairo:
qualcuno forse la conoscerà,
è il vecchio cimitero
monumentale del Cairo
dove nel corso degli anni
centinaia di migliaia di persone,
in gran parte proveniente
dalle prime ondate
di profughi palestinesi, anni fa,
ha trovato alloggio
nelle tombe, nei mausolei
del vecchio cimitero
monumentale del Cairo,
creando una vera e propria società
all'interno del Cairo.
Il Cairo considera queste persone
dei reietti della società,
li considera immorali
perché vivono tra i morti.
Loro hanno ricreato un loro ecosistema,
un loro ambiente sociale in equilibrio.
Eppure non esistono, per gli altri.
Questa persona vive lì.
Aveva cominciato come custode
di questo mausoleo,
e negli anni si è trasferito
a vivere in questa tomba
con la sua famiglia.
Ho scattato una fotografia,
ha fatto il giro di internet,
non ha cambiato né il mio,
né il suo mondo né il mondo in generale:
io sono tornato e lui è ancora lì.
Anche queste persone
vivono nella città dei morti,
e quando le ho chiesto
di fargli un ritratto fotografico
questa signora anziana col nipotino
si è messa in posa vicino a questa tomba,
diciamo la tomba di famiglia
nel loro cortiletto.
Io ho chiesto se fosse un loro parente:
Mi han detto: no,
ma viviamo qua da tanti anni,
è come se lo fosse ormai.
Vorremmo un ritratto con lui".
Questa mia fotografia
non ha cambiato il loro mondo:
loro vivono ancora lì tra i morti.
Quest'altra persona, invece, è Sergei.
Sergei vive in un centro di accoglienza
per senza fissa dimora.
Già questo dal punto di vista semantico
è una cosa che mi fa imbestialire.
Abbiamo bisogno di definire una persona
per quello che non ha,
invece che per quello che ha:
senza fissa dimora.
È russo.
Da tanti anni, ormai,
è in mezzo a una strada
e non parla più della sua famiglia.
Quando mi ha chiesto un ritratto,
mi ha chiesto di fargli un ritratto a metà
perché dice che gli manca
qualcosa nella sua vita,
ovviamente gli manca tantissimo.
Sono tornato a casa, lui è ancora lì.
Questa foto, probabilmente bella
o non bella, ha fatto il giro di internet,
non ha cambiato il suo mondo.
Anche Carmine vive
in quel centro d'accoglienza.
Vive in un mondo tutto suo:
dice che coltiva api, ama le sue api,
non parla più della sua famiglia,
si chiude in un silenzio imbarazzante
quando gli si chiede la sua storia.
Questa foto non ha cambiato il suo mondo:
vive ancora per strada.
Ci sono tanti esempi,
accelero un pochettino.
Queste sono delle foto
delle barche, dei trabiccoli,
con i quali i profughi dal Medio Oriente
arrivano a Lampedusa.
E continuano ad arrivare ogni giorno.
Scappano dalle loro situazioni,
dalle loro tragedie umane e sociali.
Questa foto non ha cambiato il loro mondo,
e continuano ad arrivare,
eppure l'ho raccontata.
Non è servito a niente.
Questa persona vive invece
in un campo profughi di Bourj el-Barajneh,
nella periferia di Beirut.
È un campo profughi grandissimo,
ma che non è mappato
nella carta di Beirut.
Lui vende, al caldo, gira per il campo
vendendo gelati e coni gelato.
Suda, suda tantissimo.
Cammina e vende gelati in un campo
dove tutti crescono senza diritti sociali.
Questa foto non ha cambiato il suo mondo.
È ancora lì che vende, in questo momento -
adesso starà dormendo,
ma domani mattina si alzerà
e continuerà a vendere gelati.
Nello stesso campo
ho conosciuto questa bambina.
Per lei quel campo profughi,
mi raccontava - cioè mi traducevano -
era il suo grande parco giochi.
Lo trovava smisurato, enorme.
Non sa ancora che sta crescendo
senza nessun diritto
in un campo neanche, come vi ho detto,
mappato, nella città di Beirut.
Probabilmente rimarrà là
tutta la sua vita, senza diritti.
Questa foto non solo non ha cambiato
il suo mondo adesso,
ma non l'avrà cambiato
neanche nei prossimi 20, 30 o 40 anni.
Quindi il loro mondo non è cambiato.
La fotografia, probabilmente,
non è servita a niente.
Le mie fotografie sono
state un buco nell'acqua
e probabilmente hanno
semplicemente assolto
al loro compito di solleticare
il mio egocentrismo nel mostrarvele dopo.
Peraltro un fattore
molto tipico di noi fotografi,
essere piuttosto egocentrici.
Loro sono ancora lì.
Quello che invece,
probabilmente, è cambiato,
è nel chi ha scattato la fotografia.
Perché io sono tornato,
io adesso conosco quelle storie.
So che loro, domani mattina,
si alzeranno e sono ancora lì.
So che c'è qualcuno che vive ancora
là sotto, per strada,
dietro l'angolo di casa mia.
So che se voglio scendo
e ci sono mille situazioni
di disagio sociale
che posso, e devo raccontare.
Quindi, voi adesso -
in qualche maniera vi ho fregato,
perché vi ho detto
che la fotografia sociale
non cambia il mondo;
ma vi ho raccontato delle storie,
che adesso anche voi conoscete.
Perché, come diciamo spesso anche noi,
ci sono storie che devono
e possono essere raccontate.
E probabilmente è il raccontare
queste piccole grandi storie,
chiedendo alla gente
di scendere per strada
e raccontarle con noi,
che cambia il mondo alla fine.
Questo è il nostro concetto
di buon uso del mondo.
È un buon uso non di persone naif.
Non siamo sognatori, non siamo idealisti,
non siamo attivisti,
noi non prendiamo parte
nei cambiamenti sociali,
nei movimenti politici ecc.
Noi raccontiamo le storie.
Lo facciamo in maniera neutra,
neutrale e gratuita
per chi non se lo può permettere.
Perché ci sono storie
che devono essere raccontate,
storie che vogliono essere raccontate
e storie che devono essere conosciute.
Grazie.
(Applausi)